12 June now by the mayor of Liverpool
Joe Anderson thank you very much indeed
for being with us on Sky News that this
evening so if the government says
schools can and must reopen on June the
1st that will Liverpool Schools defy
that simply yes we will make sure that
it's safe for our children so they tend
to school
yeah I've listened just to the the guy
who heads up an Academy trust and I've
listened to other people today talking
about social deprivation and now it's
impacting on some of those chilled and
that living in poverty in places and we
should therefore get the back to school
quick I think that's an absolute
disgrace and an insult to their children
whether they live in disadvantaged
communities or households because I will
only allow schools to take children back
in and teaching staff an ancillary stuff
if it's safe to do so this has got
nothing to do with disadvantage it's got
nothing to do with politics it's got
everything to do with the safety of
children as well yeah at the UK
government's chief pandemic modeler
Professor Graham medley says this he
says current understanding is that
children are not playing a key role in
transmitting the disease that the
disease I mean what scientific modelling
or evidence are you basing your concerns
on okay well let me it's not based on
scientific model and it's based on
common sense and and the bottom line is
I've heared scientists give different
opinions and different views these same
scientists told us that care homes there
was no problem with their homes and
debris no infection rates and care homes
this is the same government ministers
who are taking advice from these
scientists who tell us it's not so safe
to travel on public transport but it's
safe to send your kids to school I'm
sorry with the infection rates as high
as they are in Liverpool I think I'm
better qualified the Longwood parents
teachers ed teachers and the
professional staff who work for me to
decide where and when it's safe to do so
to send schools you said yeah I know
sort sorry to interpose eyes for
interrupting do you know how many new
recorded cases were confirmed in the
a 24-hour period in Liverpool probably
about 40 I haven't looked it was it let
him actually according to what we tell
things well but the figures in terms of
the our race infection raised in
Liverpool is higher than it is for
instance in London there were like two
weeks ahead of us so whilst I accept
that it might be alright for London and
it might be alright for different places
at the moment we don't feel it's safe II
and in Liverpool so whether the
infection rate was 11 today or 40 you
know we get all different levels and
different types of information on a
daily basis about who you believe what
I'm listening to is clearly the concerns
of my public health officials that the
head teachers the parents in our city as
I said it's not about politics this is
about who can decide about the safety I
have a responsibility we have a
responsibility is the local education
Authority to study I have I have a duty
to make sure that children are safe the
staff are safe our teachers are safe in
schools and that's what will ensure we
do if we find and if we can get it safe
what on the fifteenth when our schools
retain after half in and it sinks to do
so would say in schools then that's
exactly what we'll do we're not looking
for confrontation which is simple pain
that we feel at this juncture at this
time it's not safe
yeah I understand that but but globally
the evidence suggests children are far
far less likely to get coronavirus or to
pass it on than adults started that
money I mean your black and white it's
not black and white but and we
understand the evidence is suggesting
and the addenda teachers not need to be
prepared to take even if it's a small
risk in order to get I've told them back
to school though we shouldn't take any
risk we shouldn't take any risk and the
bottom line about you saying about
children are less likely to you know and
okay they'll survive the disease and all
of those things and that might be true
the scientific evidence that argues
against that well let let's just accept
that that's the case what about if those
children then pass on that infection
rates well
grandparents they might live with or two
parents that are elderly or for shielded
family members there's a lot of things
that need to be taken into consideration
at this moment in Liverpool the
infection rate is still too high you
might talk about there only being eight
cases disclosed today I haven't seen no
figures what I do not what I do know is
that Liverpool is close to the 1% sorry
now as far as I'm concerned no I don't
want to see a spike in infection rates
here in the city what I'm saying Benny
very clearly if it's safe to do so and
only if it's safe to do so our channel
then it'll go back to school that's what
we all want don't want to see
disadvantaged kids or kids that are
disappointed in this city we understand
the importance of education but health
and safety and their welfare truths that
but by what I wonder I wonder why when
in in in your region there are high
rates of infection in places like
Lancaster and in Barrow as well and yet
they're not saying that all schools need
to be closed and weren't we open on June
the 1st they've got high rates infecting
the Liverpool and I don't know what the
same I haven't got you know I often hear
those figures or those dates that those
statistics that you've just given about
other areas what I can tell you is is
what I know about my neighborhoods my
part of the country that I represent
nuts Liverpool and what I would say very
very loud and clear is that when we're
satisfied that it's safe for our
children whatever the school it might be
in one area and not the same in another
area of Liverpool in a particular school
but when it's safe to do so we allow how
are you guarantee it's safe there how
can you possibly ever guarantee it's
safe
well well that's exactly the point is
that we can't hundred percent gaps
against claims those won't reopen it for
months and months
well we'll expect let me finish we can't
guarantee the safety of children in
normal circumstances but this isn't
normal circumstances we know that
there's a an infection rate by a virus
that infects by stealth and I want to
make sure that that children that go
into school don't infect one another and
that
transmitted to the home environment or
to teaching stuff or to ancillary stuff
you're not listening to me what I'm
clearly saying is that when it's safe to
do so we will happily let children go
back to school this isn't looking for
confrontation with anybody it's simply
saying that the infection rates in our
city at this time and I know better than
some wait all official or anthem or
scientists who tells me differently and
listen to our head teachers we listen to
our governor's we listen to our staff
and the trade unions here as well and
are more importantly our parents and if
then when we feel it's safe for children
to eat a inter-school that will happen
okay we're here you loud and clear Joe
Anderson Marilyn Poole thank you very
much